get on your side tonight making a list
checking it twice isn't only a good idea
for Santa Claus our Savvy Shopper and
consumer savings expert has an approach
to our holiday shopping before we hit
the stores
a lot of people are worried about
affording the holidays this year with
Rising inflation and a turbulent stock
market the earlier you prepare your
finances for the holiday season the
better according to budgeting expert
Andrea warrock she says before you even
begin look at your finances figure out
how much you can afford to pay for gifts
set your budget by making a gifting
strategy list out the people who you
want to buy a gift for maybe that means
cutting back on who you give gifts to
this year because you don't have enough
money to spend speak with your family
and friends about gift expectations
instead of everyone buying a gift in
your friend group she suggests a secret
Santa gift exchange set a small budget
cap so no one feels pressure to spend
more that they can afford if you're not
good at making lists then use this free
app you can use an app like Santa's bag
it makes it really easy where you can
enter in each person's name gift idea a
budget and then the actual amount you
spent per person so at any time you can
open the app to see how much you've
spent in total there's also Christmas
gift list gift tracker and red laser
anything to help you with better buying
decisions so you don't overspend keep in
mind just because something is on sale
doesn't mean you need to buy it keeping
track of your purchases will help you
especially if you started early in
December you can look to see how much
you've spent and then decide all right
I'm done or maybe I could afford one
more thing
she adds consider making homemade gifts
you know those type of presents are
always great ways to save money while
creating something memorable consider
photos for grandparents or cookies for
your kids teachers